I know that it's been an aspiration of
yours to play and let's face it an
aspiration of a lot of people and
entertainment to play a Marvel superhero
because the minute you get signed up as
a Marvel superhero
I mean automatic guaranteed franchise
yep for years and years to come
and is this something is is this
something that you think you could
accomplish I think of where is the
Indian superhero there's there's so many
of us and when I saw Black Panther it
just made my heart swell and I was like
it is possible for us now I want to be
the first Indian Marvel superhero that
some have you thought about this much
have you thought of I mean I don't I
honestly don't know if such a hero
exists already in their cannon but do
you have an idea for what I do so they
have black mantle where is brown cow
brown cow brown cow all right so so
picture the scene I love that we're a
part of the pitch now going brown cow so
Andy and I are big studio heads hope I'm
smoking so it's like evangelist 15 the
world is gonna die everybody's unhappy
people have half the Avengers are gone
the guy with the arrows is out of arrows
you know the Hulk is skinny again yeah
yeah
Iron Man is melted whatever and then
Thanos is about to take over and all of
a sudden you hear and it's not even me
just a guy I have hired to go man and
then I walk out and like six Auto shoot
milk into Thanos his face
and he's like offended but kind of
delighted at the same time and then I do
three things in quick succession it's
it's an Indian attack right right so
first there's like a line which is like
a cheesy lead written movie line so I
kind of go hey Thanos you don't know me
but now we have beef
[Applause]
then after that you know the first thing
I do is have buy up all of his land and
I sell it back to him at an 83 percent
see that coming so now Kairos is
bankrupt yeah he needs money right what
does he sell jewelry right so he's got a
golden bracelet with like red pink
yellow jewels on it yeah who likes that
kind of jewelry Indian girls I buy all
of the the stones from Thanos right then
I go for his family I don't hurt his
family I marry his daughter so now he
has to deal with half Indian
grandchildren who the rest of his life
and then the final thing is my
superpower Thanos will attack me he'll
punch me you know what is brown cow
superpower he gets to summon 1.3 billion
people so I put a press release out
saying American man attacks Hindu cows
1.3 billion Indians we put heroes
outside and mess him up yeah right and
even if he kills half of us that is 700
million Indian people waiting for Thanos
out it's much better than Aquaman I got
angry you've got so many people you can
call on yeah that's a fantastic pitch
that UV is probably not gonna get me
never I know I hate till I'm gonna lie
to you that's going to get me thank you